a lot of people have been asking me what
I thought of Insidious the red door so
let's talk about it I thought this was a
good solid mid-tier Insidious I did
enjoy watching it so here are three
things that I liked about it number one
the character Dynamics and relationships
I especially liked the character of
Renee the mom in this movie She's put in
this position where she has to lie to
her family for their own good you can
just tell that there's a lot of weight
that she has to carry in doing that
number two I thought the jump scares
were really well handled it wasn't a
total jump scare fest which made the
scares that were in the movie A lot more
effective I think that they were
intelligently placed and that helped
make them more effective when we did see
them and number three it respected the
lore of the original movies without
feeling too formulaic anytime you're
dealing with Insidious and the further
there's that temptation to go back and
revisit different scenes from another
angle and they do that in the movie but
it's not just for Nostalgia purposes it
is actually to drive the story forward
in this movie that being said I
obviously don't think it was a perfect
movie so let me know if you'd like to
see some things that I disliked about it